thanks bianca and we have new cova data  coming here into our newsroom at noon  nevada's test positivity is holding  steady at 12.3 percent while the county  reports 11 percent the county is also  reporting 183 cases per every one  hundred thousand over the last week the  number needs to drop below a hundred for  restrictions to ease you can always scan  this qr code you see on your screen  right now it'll take you straight to a  breakdown of our full covid report on  eightnewsnow.com  if you still need the covet vaccine the  westgate has a clinic today it's open  from two to four inside the cabaret  theater you can also get a flu shot but  you'll have to show your insurance card  for that one